at 65,000 tonnes HMS Queen Elizabeth is
the UK's largest ever warship the
aircraft carriers flight deck has an
area equal to 60 tennis courts that's
big enough for four jumbo jets but the
planes lining up on these decks will
have considerably more firepower the
f-35 Joint Strike Fighter is one of the
world's leading jets capable of
supersonic speeds and vertical landings
there's also the fax close-in weapon
system that can fire 3,000 rounds per
minute at incoming enemy aircraft and
missiles a long-range radar can track up
to 1,000 contacts in the air or on the
sea in a 250 mile radius
made by a consortium of defense
companies the ship is the most complex
ever made in the UK it's taken 28
million hours to design and build the
queen elizabeth-class along with a
sister carrier still in construction the
total project is costing over 10 billion
dollars the ship is so massive that
those onboard
each have handheld GPS devices to help
them navigate it one more break from
tradition the Queen will christen the
ship with a bottle of whiskey rather
than champagne in a nod to the ship's
birth in Scotland
Tom Gibson Bloomberg